[Música]
bienvenidos al debate de france 24 soy
santiago lópez gonzález tres presidentes
en solamente una semana manifestaciones
muertos e incertidumbre en todos los
sentidos política económica social y por
supuesto sanitaria por la pandemia pero
atraviesa una de sus crisis más agudas
de la historia reciente de ese país la
investidura de francisco sagasti como
presidente interino da una pequeña luz
de esperanza para que este país comience
su camino hacia la estabilidad esto fue
lo que dijo sagasti en su toma de
posesión
en estos momentos de crisis sin
precedentes y agudizados por estas
catástrofes y por los problemas que
tiene nuestro país los problemas
económicos de salud sociales y de
seguridad es fundamental
es absolutamente necesario mantener la
calma la tranquilidad y la ecuanimidad
tomemos estos tiempos turbulentos como
un llamado a la acción al compromiso de
todos nosotros peruanas y peruanas de
buena voluntad para cambiar esta
situación y salir de la crisis
quién es francisco sagasti cuáles deben
ser sus prioridades cuáles pueden ser
los pasos a seguir para estabilizar esta
nación suramericana hoy en el debate de
france 24 hacemos foco en perú
acompáñenos para analizar este tema
hemos invitado a elena al vitesse ella
es analista y docente de derecho
constitucional y también es coordinadora
de la maestría de derecho constitucional
de la pontificia universidad católica de
perú también está con nosotros samuel
abbado él es abogado constitucionalista
y también es docente de derecho
constitucional en la universidad
católica del perú y también en la
universidad del pacifico ambos se
encuentran allí en la capital peruana ya
ellos también se une y según esta
conversación francisco zacarías nuestro
corresponsal permanente allí en la
capital peruana que nos ha reportado a
lo largo de estas semanas los diferentes
hechos que han tenido lugar en ese país
ustedes también hacen parte de este
debate desde sus hogares pueden dejar
sus comentarios y sus preguntas a través
de las redes sociales france24
sant y luego deje todos sus comentarios
con el numeral el debe
efe 24 los invito para que respondan
entonces la siguiente pregunta cree que
el mandatario en transición francisco
sagasti logrará garantizar la
estabilidad en perú déjenos sus
comentarios y los leeremos al final del
programa pues tenemos a los invitados y
tenemos el tema quiero comenzar primero
con francisco zacarías nuestro
corresponsal para que nos comenten y nos
haga un barrido rápido
francisco sobre los hechos que han
tenido lugar hoy en lima esta toma de
posesión allí en el congreso adelante
buenas noches la ceremonia de
juramentación de francisco sagasti como
presidente interino del perú fue mucho
más que emotiva
inicio rindiendo un homenaje a los
jóvenes jacques brian pintado y también
a inti sotelo ambos jóvenes murieron el
producto de la violencia policial
durante las jornadas de protesta el
mandatario pidió perdón a sus familiares
quienes se encontraban al interior del
hemiciclo y también pidió perdón a todos
aquellos que fueron afectados en estas
jornadas de protesta el mandatario ha
dicho que uno de sus principales medidas
luego de juramentar el cargo va a ser
tratar de hallar a los desaparecidos que
partan participaron en la marcha y no se
encuentran en sus domicilios y sus
familiares están preocupados por ellos
también ha señalado que le ha pedido a
la fiscalía que enfatiza acciones y
aseguró que no habrá impunidad contra él
hacia todos aquellos que ejercieron
abuso de autoridad y cometieron hechos
delictivos
francisco sagasti ha prometido que las
elecciones de abril próximo que se
celebran elecciones presidenciales y
congresales serán totalmente limpias y
transparentes y habrá neutralidad y
garantiza el mejor desarrollo para los
partidos políticos ha señalado que en lo
que se refiere a la salud una de sus
principales acciones va a ser fortalecer
y atender la mejor atención contra la
pandemia del cobi 19 gracias francisco
por este reporte contándonos lo que ha
sucedido hoy en la ciudad de lima voy
entonces a comenzar el análisis con
elena al vitesse allí en la capital
peruana y comienzo elena por
preguntándole si desde su análisis y
desde su conocimiento y también teniendo
en cuenta la amplia la vasta trayectoria
política que tiene francisco sagasti es
el personaje indicado para liderar a
perú en estos ocho meses de transición
para
a lograr llegar a ese puerto que son las
elecciones presidenciales que empiece ya
de pronto dar un poco de estabilidad a
este país
buenas noches santiago gracias por la
pregunta
creo que este esta llegada a francisco
sagasti es una llegada que
ha sido planteada de alguna manera en
las calles porque ha sido un proceso
político dada una ruptura
inconstitucional creo yo de las
relaciones entre el parlamento y el
ejecutivo y un uso abusivo de por parte
del congreso embarcar a un presidente
sobre la base de un supuesto que
requiere una interpretación más profunda
que se ajuste a los elementos de pesos y
contrapesos que tiene la constitución
entonces dado que el congreso realizó
esta acción se ha requerido que el mismo
a través del proceso de sucesión
planteado lo resuelva lo resuelva
eligiendo entre quienes no votaron a
favor de la vacancia y entre la persona
que ha demostrado en el parlamento que
ha tenido mayor vocación de consenso y
reúne experiencias y cualidades creo
necesarias para conducir esta transición
hay que recordar que las elecciones en
el perú están convocadas para el 11 de
abril son 8 meses no donde
la agenda puede ser mucha no muy grande
o muy vasta pero lo que se requiere es
atender lo urgente y que es urgente
garantizar que esas elecciones sean
transparentes y
que permitan elegir a un nuevo gobierno
y atender la pandemia y el presidente ha
dicho un justo medio entre la atención
de la salud y la búsqueda de
recuperación económica no en un
escenario de atender de urgente en este
momento que es identificar las
responsabilidades de quienes lesionaron
derechos fundamentales durante las
protestas legítimas de la población con
las prioridades de la agenda porque esa
es una de mis siguientes preguntas y ya
vamos para allá quiero hacerles la misma
pregunta a samuel sábado sobre sus
impresiones su opinión sobre francisco
sagasti sobre si es el personaje ideal
en este momento para llevar a perú en
esta transición
como nos han quedado muchas gracias por
la entrevista saludos a los televidentes
y a los oyentes este importante programa
saludos a la profesora vistes y sin duda
es la persona ideal creo que es la
persona que logró el consenso en el
congreso
a la presidencia del congreso con 97
votos de 130 recordemos en una primera
votación una candidata no obtuvo el
consenso necesario y el señor francisco
sagasti lo logró el día de ayer en una
fecha histórica además santiago por el
día de ayer hace 20 años también se
inició una transición democrática cuando
el presidente en ese momento
quien fue eximida es el presidente de la
republica valentín paniagua fue elegido
presidente del confesor fíjate la
casualidad hace 20 años luego de la
caída de fujimori el 16 de noviembre o
el día como ayer fue elegido presidente
del congreso de valentín paniagua y
luego presidió la transición ayer 16 de
noviembre debe 20 años después asume el
mismo reto luego de la difícil elección
con 97 votos el señor nosotras te va a
asumir los retos de la transición me
prece simbólico pero también me parece
un dato
preocupante porque en 20 años volvemos a
casi lo mismo en 2020 años después
estamos dando inicio a otra etapa donde
luego de una crisis política tenemos que
ir a la transición pero evidentemente me
parece la persona más adecuada para
asumir el cargo y el discurso de hoy ha
dado muestra de ello
samuel a una fecha entonces es muy
importante para los peruanos como usted
lo dice porque marca transiciones pero
también preocupa por lo que usted dice
porque en 20 años el país vuelve a caer
en este espiral de crisis política que
vamos a analizar más adelante quiero
preguntarle a francisco esa caridad
nuestro corresponsal francisco usted ha
estado a lo largo de estas semanas en la
calle así sigue el london siguiéndole el
pulso a estas manifestaciones ciudadanas
y veíamos que los peruanos salieron a
manifestarse contra la destitución del
presidente de vizcarra pero no querían
que vizcarra regresara al poder esta
manera en contra de ese procedimiento
que había tenido lugar en el congreso y
luego se manifestaron en contra de
manuel merino y esta presidencia
interina que fue instaurada
pocos días y que duró solamente unas
cuantas horas como reciben entonces los
peruanos allí en las calles que lo que
usted ha visto y ha palpado allí
sobre la elección de sagasti como nueva
presidente interina
justamente lo que veníamos reportando
que estos días
ayer cuando se haga así fue denominado
presidente del parlamento al momento de
retirarse había más de 1000 personas en
los alrededores de la plaza bolívar
ellos sólo saludaron el mandatario salió
por la puerta donde se encontraban los
manifestantes que habían venido y los
gritos fueron no de protesta sino de
júbilo de entusiasmo con banderas
ondeantes y muchos aplausos en la
población de está en estos momentos
exigiendo que la clase política respete
a la población respete la democracia y
sobre todo traten de reducir las brechas
sociales y para ello el gobierno tiene
que tender puentes con la población con
la ciudadanía que se ha visto afectada
por la pandemia del cob y 19 por la
economía que este año va a caer 13
puntos y hay más de 6 millones de
personas que han perdido sus puestos de
trabajo según las cifras oficiales
diversos analistas dicen que es más y
borraría los nueve millones de personas
entonces esto ha sido en la sintonía que
tiene sagasti con la población que es
mucho distinta a la que venía realizando
manuel merino que se rodeó de un sector
conservador de la clase política está
garcía en ese sentido en este mensaje a
los peruanos ha dicho que él va a
ejercer de tal manera que las puertas de
palacio del gobierno van a estar
abiertas hacia aquellos que quieran
presentar alguna denuncia por alguna
mala praxis del estado o también para
participar una propuesta ciudadana en
beneficio de la gobernabilidad para
muchos que han estado acá presentes
salieron de alguna manera tranquilos y
es este esta política de diálogo se
denotó
el nuevo presidente un trato más más
humano más digamos cerca al ciudadano el
hecho de haber rendido un homenaje a los
jóvenes que fallecieron ha llenado de
esa conexión que faltaba con la
población y precisamente de sagasti ha
dicho que la clase política no estuvo a
la altura de las circunstancias y que
motivaron todas estas situaciones que se
encadenaron en actos en las últimas
horas y ha mencionado que ahora en la
ciudadanía el aspecto de ellos tiene más
protagonismo los jóvenes y va hacia
ellos esta conexión
elena ya sabemos que la agenda y la
crisis que tiene él para el perú es muy
profunda hay muchos temas para abordar y
por lo menos francisco sagasti en su
discurso allí en la toma de posesión
pues mostró estar con buena voluntad de
realizar muchas cosas y por lo menos
comenzar
a empezar a mover un poco y encausar la
situación hacia una mejora en el país
cuáles son esos desafíos cuáles son esas
prioridades que debe tener este gobierno
interino teniendo en cuenta que
solamente va a estar al mando ocho meses
en efecto tiene tiene ocho meses por
delante de santiago pero retos
importantes no menores y creo que ha
empezado con muy buen pie como lo
comentaba francisco desde desde
parlamento ha tenido gestos importantes
desde el día de ayer la busca de
acercamiento a la población y él en su
discurso sincerar que el perú ya partía
con la pandemia de una situación de
inequidad y que es necesario buscar
encontrar metas a cumplir en estos ocho
meses es un discurso que se acerca a lo
que queremos y lo que creo que quiere la
ciudadanía que ha salido a protestar
primero que se garanticen unas
elecciones limpias y transparentes pero
también una clase política que sea leal
al texto constitucional a los derechos
de las personas que busquen busquen
evitar prácticas de corrupción
pero a la vez es la lucha contra la
pandemia no en la mejora de los
servicios de salud
el bienestar de la población y a la par
la reactivación económica también es
importante como lo decía hace un momento
a la investigación y el apoyo a esa
investigación que pueda dar el
ministerio público para identificar a
los responsables jurídicos pero también
desde el punto de vista de la política
es importante y que pueda de repente en
su acta en el parlamento impulsar las
investigaciones para identificar las
responsabilidades políticas de las
personas los dos jóvenes que han
fallecido los heridos y las
desapariciones no es importante también
creo yo y creo que ya lo ha hecho en su
discurso atender otros derechos de la
ciudadanía que han sido afectados por la
pandemia como es el derecho a la
educación ha tenido un buen porcentaje
de su discurso orientado a como la
educación va a ser prioritaria en cuanto
a fortalecer los mecanismos de enseñanza
remota particularmente la enseña la así
que cierre de brechas para llegar a toda
la población con el fortalecimiento de
educa perú es un programa ya iniciado
creo también que otro reto importante
que va a tener el parlamento con el
parlamento y por eso es importante que
él haya sido designado como presidente
es trabajar de manera conjunta para
equilibrar y gestionar responsablemente
las finanzas públicas esto es básico
porque el perú luego de la pandemia ha
entrado a un escenario de crisis
económica y baja recaudación en esa
medida no si queremos satisfacer
derechos como salud de educación
este elemento este reto tratar de sanear
las las financias públicas es muy
importante además de seguir teniendo
gestos de acercamiento con la población
que está expectante para estos ocho
meses porque en las calles ya se
empezaba
a sentir una voz de necesidad de reforma
de la constitución y si durante estos
ocho meses se abre al diálogo a las
expectativas estos reclamos van a ser
conducidos por cauces pacíficos
armónicos que es lo que se espera en un
estado constitucional clara samuel ya
vimos la agenda es larguísima la
cantidad de cosas que hay por delante
para hacer en este país como en la
mayoría de países de américa latina pues
son muchos y sobre todo con estas crisis
desatadas por la pandemia de 1.019 hay
buenas intenciones de ahí a que pueda
actuar y llevar a cabo muchas de estas
ideas ya veremos que van diciendo los
días pero qué tan fácil lo tiene este
presidente interino con el congreso
porque todas estas medidas y solamente
ocho meses necesitan agilidad de trámite
en el legislativo como están allí las
cargas que tanto podría tener a favor
este presidente interino allí en el
congreso
bueno en primer lugar creo que la agenda
debe ser una agenda básica la agenda
básica y el segundo lugar lo urgente es
designar un gabinete que inspira
confianza
el gabinete anterior no inspiraba
ninguna confianza
no tenía ninguna cercanía con la
realidad del país y en tercer lugar
tratar de fortalecer las relaciones con
el congreso el presidente proviene de
una agrupación política que no tiene
mayoría en el congreso
en el congreso estamos hablando de
diversos intereses del juego que han
permitido que el lunes 2 de noviembre se
va a que a un presidente y luego se
designe a otro presidente como usted
decía en tres semanas en una semana
hemos tenido tres presidentes entonces
es un congreso que de verdad no tiene
una unidad de criterio hay muchos
intereses en juego de diversa
envergadura hay congresistas que están
con investigaciones en trámite entonces
va a ser indispensable que fortalezca y
establezca relaciones de coordinación
porque de lo contrario haber conflictos
dejara las elecciones varios
congresistas van a estar interesados en
aprobar leyes populistas y cuando el
ejecutivo comience a observarla se van a
presentar los primeros choques o
conflictos con el congreso de este
ejecutivo
habrá que ver cómo se solucionan para
evitar esta mayoría parlamentaria
parlamentaria intenté intenté volver a
repetir la historia yo confío en que
esto no se repite que lo intente
embarcar nuevamente al presidente actual
si es que lo comparte ese que lo acepta
se plantean los planteamientos que hacen
un congreso espero por eso es
indispensable tratar de establecer
buenas relaciones progresos pero también
es cierto que los congresistas han
demostrado en los últimos días y en las
últimas semanas y con sus leyes una
irresponsabilidad absoluta voy a hacer
la ronda a la inversa continúo con
samuel ya le doy la palabra elena y a
francisco precisamente el congreso es
uno de los puntos de discordia y de
conexión y desconexión mejor con la
ciudadanía puede que con el presidente y
hasta con las políticas que estaban
llevando vizcarra había cierta sintonía
en muchas de ellas con la ciudadanía
pero tal parece que a los peruanas lo
que les inconforme lo que los tienen
conforme
el congreso como tal las políticas que
están instaurando la forma como funciona
la alta corrupción que es tal vez un mal
generalizado en la mayoría de los
congresos de américa latina' cómo
empezar
samuel a mejorar esa relación entre el
ciudadano y el congreso de perú
bueno y la manera de legitimarse del
congreso es a partir de sus actos y
ahora se ha presentado un actor que no
parecía tan visible es hacerlo son los
jóvenes los productores en buena en
buena cuenta ha visto que se ha llamado
la generación del bicentenario ha
contribuido a que el señor merino se
vaya y ha contribuido decididamente
incluso con el sacrificio de dos vidas
que ha sido fruto de los abusos claros
en la policía liderado por las
autoridades políticas en ese momento en
consecuencia una primera forma de
acercarse a la ciudadanía es a partir de
esos actos que no comen que no aprueben
leyes que no tienen ningún sentido que
no comiencen a petardear al ejecutivo s
y eso edificio no es fácil porque
estamos cercanos a la fecha electoral y
en consecuencia es probable que el
congreso trate de insistir en su agenda
pero habrá que ver también es cierto que
de cara a las elecciones va a tener que
cuidarse porque muchas agrupaciones
políticas se han visto deslegitimadas
con las medidas adoptadas la vacancia
del señor
y la designación del señor venido de la
manera como lo ha hecho ha generado
muchos cuestionamientos de las
agrupaciones políticas que generaron lo
que vemos en las cámaras las marchas de
cantidad de jóvenes es rechaza en este
tipo de clase política helena usted ya
lo estaba mencionando en su intervención
anterior una posible reforma a la
constitución peruana sería uno de los
pasos para algunos de los gobiernos que
llegue a la silla presidencial alguien
pero era también una de las conclusiones
a las que llegábamos en un debate previo
aquí en france 24 cuando la crisis
recién estaba comenzando y nuestros
analistas invitados nos decían que la
misma carta magna de perú tiene unos
vacíos que son los que hacen que sea
este país propenso a este tipo de crisis
cíclicas ya que se presente en estos
escenarios que el congreso restituya el
presidente de una manera rápida y que
tal parece que tiene las herramientas a
favor del congreso y no a favor del jefe
de estado que tan viable puede ser esa
reforma a la constitución que también le
lo ve a usted con
con el congreso que hay o que puede
instaurar sé qué tan rápido podría ser y
qué tan viable puede ser
bueno gracias nuevamente por la pregunta
creo creo que ella es el escenario de
transición no es el escenario para la
reforma constitucional en la agenda es
muy acotada y va a ser un trabajo
importante el poder tender puentes y
llegar a acuerdos con el congreso y eso
va a ser suficiente creo en los 8 meses
pero sí creo no que este escenario de
transición y los gestos de apertura son
la población particularmente como se
señalaba a mí y mi colega el doctor
samuel abad con quien me tengo mucho
gusto de compartir ahora no es
particularmente los jóvenes no la
pregunta es cuánto los jóvenes se ven
representados en esta constitución y
cuanto eventualmente porque además de
ser una norma política no va a ser una
norma también es un acuerdo político lo
que se busca es que de alguna manera nos
veamos todos reflejados en ella no en
cuanto esta pandemia ha dejado no para
dar cuenta de la fragilidad
institucional y de la debilidad
y de la falta de protección que tenemos
en el perú hacia las personas y eso
supone que miremos la constitución que
su cambio no va a ser la transformación
automática o por arte de magia pero es
un primer paso pero antes de eso hay que
dar un amplio debate escuchar a todos
los actores y ciertamente tomar atención
en cómo estos conflictos políticos que
se han dado en el perú entre el
parlamento y el ejecutivo tienen que ver
con que la persona que resulta elegida
como presidente cuando no cuenta con una
mayoría política en el parlamento se ve
expuesto a este tipo de amenazas y
jaloneos no y vacancias que provocan lo
que hemos visto hasta una dimensión
trágica como la muerte de los dos
jóvenes
si francisco nuestro corresponsal allí
en la ciudad de lima elena habla de
escuchar a la ciudadanía hablan tanto
samuel como elena de los jóvenes que es
lo que le reclaman los peruanos los
ciudadanos de a pie al gobierno en esta
crisis en la que están en este momento y
que los ha llevado a las calles de las
diferentes ciudades de este país en los
últimos días
me reclamo en principio que se respeten
la democracia porque ellos han sentido
que no se respeta el voto ciudadano en
las elecciones de 2016 ellos eligieron a
un presidente que fue pedro pablo
kuczynski y también el mismo orden
democrático permitió que en el
parlamento el partido fuerza popular
tuviera la mayoría de representantes
este a su vez hizo alianzas con algunas
agrupaciones políticas lo que sucede es
que desde el parlamento se le estuvo
dando obstáculos se obstaculizaba las
iniciativas de gobierno del entonces
presidente pedro pablo kuczynski y
posteriormente provocaron su destitución
esto no les ha parecido porque ellos
eligieron un gobierno y luego se hizo
una transición
entonces presidente de martín vizcarra y
generaron la misma situación de bloqueo
a iniciativas ciudadanas y luego en
causaron los dos procesos de vacancia
presidencial para poner un presidente
desde el parlamento la población no se
vio satisfecha con esta situación porque
no era lo que ellos habían elegido y
también ellos piden que se cierren las
brechas sociales mejores oportunidades
de empleo mejores oportunidades para los
jóvenes mayor acceso a la cultura a la
tecnología y al desarrollo del país si
elena abro otro capítulo pero por favor
respóndeme puntual porque ya me quedan
pocos minutos para terminar este
programa y terminar con samuel para las
conclusiones en abuso policial a lo
largo de estas manifestaciones hubo dos
personas que perdieron la vida
esto no se puede dejar pasar por encima
como un hecho aislado
que tanto puede tener esto curso en la
justicia peruana y que llegue a buen
puerto y que veamos una solución o por
lo menos medidas por parte del gobierno
para evitar estos futuro
este escenario en un futuro hecho
bien lo que estamos viendo últimamente
con los órganos de administración de
justicia en el perú es que hay parecer
una respuesta rápida para la
investigación pero esas investigaciones
se delatan se dilatan mucho en el tiempo
bien entonces esto está sucediendo con
los casos de corrupción por ejemplo que
es otro de los grandes reclamos de la
ciudadanía que se acabe con ella no
donde hay investigaciones que se han
iniciado a nivel de fiscalía hace mucho
tiempo y todavía no se concretan en una
acusación ante el poder judicial
creo que es la población que ha visto
fallecer a dos jóvenes y que tiene
todavía en nuestros hospitales jóvenes
heridos gravemente no requieren sin duda
este primer gesto que es el de la fiscal
de la nación de abrir la denuncia las
investigaciones para identificar a los
responsables pero esas investigaciones
deberían ser prontas rápidas de manera
que en breve no es decir no se espere 23
años para que hay una recién en el
inicio de un proceso judicial que lleve
a una efectiva sanción a quienes sin
duda el resultado van a resultar
responsables por el abuso el exceso de
la fuerza frente a marchas que eran
pacíficas y frente a la represión pues
se tornaron pueden los chicos han
reaccionado más que eventualmente
provocado este tipo de situaciones han
reaccionado frente a la embestida de
parte de la de la policía y además en
lima no porque en los departamentos del
perú no ha sido así ha habido marchas
pacíficas y también
no ha habido ningún tipo de problemas y
samuel su opinión al respecto sobre
estos casos de abuso policial en estas
marchas en lima
sólo tiene que investigarse hay que
investigar al expresidente medido hay
que investigar al ex presidente del
consorcio ministro es asesor ántero
flores-aráoz a quien fue el ministro del
interior al señor gonzález a las altas
autoridades de la policía nacional esto
no puede quedar impune de ge y el
ejecutivo anunciado que va a apoyar este
tipo de investigaciones
si esto quedará impune estoy seguro que
la calle va a servir nuevamente a marcha
por eso es indispensable una
investigación porque dos vidas no pueden
irse de la manera en que asumen que se
han ido por los abusos comerciales
cometidos por una mirada miope de lo que
ocurre en la realidad y sencillamente
por desconocer el derecho a la protesta
ciudadana samuel para la conclusión para
cerrar este programa y darle paso a las
redes rápidamente en 30 segundos su
conclusión que sigue para pero entonces
sigue confío que vengo la transición
pacífica y tranquila pero hay que estar
atentos la democracia hay que defenderla
y lo queremos demostrar estos hechos que
no solamente la defienden las
instituciones también la sociedad
joven que se está organizando y elena y
su conclusión 30 segundos
si yo yo coincido con samuel no creo que
la democracia y eventualmente los
derechos finalmente tienen su seña de
identidad en la reivindicación y cuando
eventualmente las autoridades y la clase
política le da la espalda pues vuelve un
legítimo derecho de la población a
reclamarlos y eso es lo que se ha dado
en este periodo de ocho días de bastante
incertidumbre para nuestro país pues
paso ahora a leer algunos de los
comentarios que dejan nuestros
televidentes a través de las redes
sociales de france 24 ya les habíamos
hecho una pregunta
allí sobre si pensaban que sagasti podía
ser el personaje que lograría garantizar
la estabilidad en perú esto no responde
en algunos de los televidentes leo a
través de youtube como peruano creo que
el pueblo
ya no cree en nadie pero por lo menos
hagas ti es un profesional de alto vuelo
ojalá no sea el títere de las mafias en
el congreso un poco lo que estábamos
comentando ahora con nuestros invitados
y julio césar gonzález 8 a través de
twitter nos comenta todo es incierto en
este país lo que sí quedó claro es que
lo ocurrido la semana pasada fue un tira
y jala de la derecha pues ya nos queda
entonces ver que lo que acontece con
este gobierno ocho meses por delante
tiene el presidente interino francisco
sagasti para comenzar a sacar a perú de
esta profunda crisis política ya veremos
qué sucede aquí teníamos las
perspectivas de dos de nuestros
invitados les agradezco por haber estado
con nosotros elena y samuel allí en la
ciudad de lima y también a francisco
sacarían nuestro corresponsal permanente
allí en perú gracias por habernos dado
detalles de lo que ha ocurrido en la
jornada de hoy a lo largo de estas
semanas a ustedes muchas gracias por la
sintonía y pueden seguir comentando y
dejando sus preguntas y comentarios a
través de las redes sociales siga con la
programación de france 24
[Música]